and you will see there are three
different tenures in which you could be
a part of and uh the first is 45 days
second is the 60 days and third is the
90 days so there are some of the common
resources which uh everyone would have
access to in all the three tenures that
is online tutorials project examples
coding sessions session recordings
online mental Support Online technical
support and obviously the certificate
after the completion of the program and
then we have a t bioinfo server so you
will have access to the demo pipelines
of those team by info server for the
analysis part also now what's the
difference between the three in the 60
days tenure you will have two different
opportunities one is the one-on-one
Mentor sessions so for example while
going through with the session you got
stuck somewhere you want to clarify your
doubts and queries with the mentor we
can organize a one-on-one exploration
you made of yours with the mentor and
you can get your queries and questions
clarified and the second is after your
45 days of training is over the rest of
the 15 days you will be devoting towards
preparing a proper research proposal and
experimental design so so how whatever
you have learned like a conceptual and
theoretical basis on conceptual
theoretical basis how you can apply it
in a real life application so definitely
our Mentor that is Dr Jeet sakal he
would help you he'll uh evaluate your
research proposal he'll see if there are
any changes that need to be done he'll
guide you accordingly and then you can
move further by developing your
independent research project also so um
and in the 90 days again you have two
opportunities with one-on-one Mentor
sessions you have an opportunity to work
on an independent research project so
the first 45 days would be devoted to
your trading and the next 45 days would
be devoted to your uh development of an
independent research project
so which includes the literature review
the data set for finalization the
methodology the results interpretation
of those results and then the report
writing in manuscript
so this is the major difference between
the three 10 years 45 60 and 90. now as
you can see on my screen that the
pricing here is right now in INR and it
would be mostly for the Asian Community
Etc so for 45 days it is 7 500 for 60
days it is uh nine triple nine and then
for 90 days it's 149 15 000.
now those who are from different
locations and uh for example those who
are from us
they can simply click on this drop down
menu and change their currency into USD
into dollars if someone is from Brazil
they can change into Brazilian currency
and if someone is from Africa they can
change accordingly into naira so here
are few of the currencies which we have
mentioned and according to your uh Place
according to your location you can
change here from this drop down menu for
example have changed it into dollars
right now so the pricing for uh 45 days
in dollars is a dollar 150 for 60 it's
300 and for 90 it's 450. and right now
we are providing everyone with a 50
scholarship on like because of it's like
it's a offer of for the Christmas or the
New Year Eve so if you can I'll just
show you how you can proceed further
with the payment you need to Simply sign
up on this learn portal and you can
redirect towards this link I guess
shubham has already shared the steps you
registered in the chat box so you can
copy paste somewhere in the notes and
you can follow those steps so you need
to Simply click uh here on buy now
button you will be redirected to this
page
and the health the coupon code for the
50 percent is health
50 click on apply
coupon is applied successfully you can
see here the total was dollar 150 after
applying 50 uh coupon the sub the total
amount is dollar 75 you need to fill
here your user details click on this
check box and select the strike payment
uh more and fill out your card details
and click on this buy now button so this
is how you can you can simply proceed
with the payment checkout so the steps
are really really easy